it was one year ago this month that the
first symptomatic cases of covet 19
were reported as the pandemic swept
across the globe
more than 65 million people have been
infected
and more than a million and a half were
killed by the virus
ramien ascencio returned to the
pandemic's ground zero
wuhan china to see how a year of living
with the coronavirus
has changed life after sickness
death and a 76 day lockdown
ruhan and its 11 million people now feel
as if the coronavirus pandemic almost
never happened
through it all american max seaward and
his wife never
left their daughter rachel had just been
born
at first it seemed so like stringent and
kind of draconian or whatever but then
in retrospect it seems like it actually
worked and now we've been able to enjoy
our lives they've been free to move and
play
since the summer at wuhan's main food
market
hungry customers are now back in long
lines
this food vendor told us he's happy and
china has crafted a proud narrative
of victory in this massive government
exhibition called lives first
people first it praises china's
president xi jinping
as the hero of the nation's war against
kovid followed by frontline health care
workers
mentions of the dead are rare now
beijing suggests
kovid may have come from abroad pointing
to the u.s
italy and india this is the wuhan
institute of virology believed by some
to be the origin of kovid 19.
now we tried to get access to this
institute for months but we were turned
down
we also tried to interview many chinese
doctors across the country
they all said they were either busy or
were frankly barred from speaking with
us
coronavirus researcher dr lin fawong did
born in shanghai he's based in singapore
let's face it a human outbreak
started in gohan just don't say it's not
from china it may prove to be wrong
at wuhan's oldest cemetery newly etched
headstones reveal
some scope of the tragedy across wuhan
there are at least 16 cemeteries just
like this
has questions his 69 year old father
died from kovit in february the
government sent
about 600 as compensation
it felt hollow i still don't know where
the virus came from
if you ask me who to blame i don't know
and he doesn't believe the government's
death toll
officially fewer than forty seven
hundred
now so many graves row after
row stand as monuments to lives lost
in the scarred city synonymous with
outbreak loss
and now one year later recovery for cbs
this morning saturday
raymie innocencio wuhan